hi I'm Paul from evolution studios and
here with me today my club mates Jamie
is tackling the point-to-point stage in
Scotland Chris we speeding through
Norway in a hyper car and car at the end
we trying to get around India where I
crash into often the point is my club
miss are all doing their own thing
but I benefit from from their actions as
part of the club even though I'm not
playing right now together were
empowered because we're earning Fame
were serving awards and will collaborate
into a lakh new cars for a long time
racing games were intimidating they
demanded that you go it alone and win
every race a lot of people that made
racing hard to enjoy in dry Club we want
to break down that wall to make it easy
for everyone who loves racing to hit the
road and have fun so back to my club
jamie has recently beaten the challenge
and thanks to his success we've all won
pagani zonda ah nice one Jamie normally
I wouldn't have found out about this
until I got back home on my PlayStation
4 but with the my drive club app I can
keep up to speed with my friends my club
and our rivals and connect to the game
anytime anyplace so I never miss a thing
in fact I can pretty much do everything
with the app that can do in the game
over the naturally race of course I'm
even able to livestream so can watch my
friends play in real time our evolution
were committed to making a truly social
racer but we're also obsessed with
detail we're proud of what we've been
able to accomplish with the visual
fidelity the detail of the cars the
detail of the tracks and today we're
really excited to show you a new element
whether Jamie would you like to tear the
wheel
just like driving in the real world
weather is lively and unpredictable
extreme conditions will drastically
change the dynamics of every race with
both car control and visibility being
affected and we're giving you control
over the weather when you set up an
event so you can make it start out dry
build up to an epic thunderstorm or
starting the blizzard that calms down
and then comes back to full force
towards the end of the race we're
working hard to make the dynamic range
sleet and snow but fun and immersive so
that it's easy to enjoy and yet
challenging for skilled drivers who'd
like to drive on the very edge of
control just like in real life raindrops
hit the ground and form puddles or dry
up depending on the temperature wipers
clear vision headlights illuminate the
road ahead and the slick roads are the
perilous edge to your race and all of
this is dynamic meaning that no two
races are ever the same and this is just
one of the many exciting features Orbitz
bring into drive club we can't wait to
share the we can't wait to share the
game with you this is just the beginning
thank you